[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est plus cool vas-y fais comme ça
t'arrange
ah c'est Steph salut à tous bah écoute
ça va ça va
content d'être là pour suivre ce joli
match
bon alors un peu évidemment visite on
connaît tous ça doit ni aussi jeune
joueur
je sais pas c'est écrit dans le chat que
tu es mute
ou pas mais voilà ouais ça doit ni pas
mal gauche connaît et vas-y c'est la
sœur de pragona non
je connais leur équipe et les bras donc
il y a 45
pré-auto je connais pas tellement et
Jennifer you bah ouais je vous American
d'ailleurs championne des États-Unis
donc moi je vous mets les caméras en
même temps mais en fait là on a un petit
problème avec le avec les caméras là on
a le stream qui qui bug pas mal donc je
vous les mets à l'occasion de toute
façon je vais je vais les mettre en
comment ça commence et je les mettrai je
pense quand on aura commencé quand on
est parti en commencer pour l'instant
[Musique]
ta voix est passée outre le mieux Fab
c'est
ça
il y a pas de souci ok ok
ok alors attends je vais faire un petit
truc hop voilà ça va aller mieux
maintenant c'est bon j'ai répondu
tac tac
sur les ventes je suis des questions je
suis je réponds à temps qui me
ok je suis survivant et du coup j'ai pas
encore du coup j'ai pas encore la partie
alors tac tac c'est bon si en fait je
garde
à l'écran qui va commencer
attends je me suis trompé je suis
complètement à la ramasse pourquoi j'ai
deux écrans moi
ok ok c'est ça en fait
excusez-moi
donc on a 45 qui va commencer ici c'est
parti OK et du coup elle est noire
contre qu'on trouvait Chali donc
bizarre de la Rousseau limo c'est ça
pour
pas un peu éviter toutes les prépas et
de toute façon il aime bien jouer des
trucs un peu originaux
c'est pas le premier coup que tu as
envie de regarder avec les Blancs quoi
c'est 3 comprises donc c'est un
sacrifice on va dire un petit peu de de
pions pour ouvrir un ouvrir la colonne D
et on voit ce que le fou des 6 lesquels
mal placé hein cette position les cases
blanches sont assez ouvertes donc il y a
quand même une petite
petite
pression il y a aussi un avantage de
développement des blancs ici on peut
imaginer
mais souvent il a l'air quand même bien
prêt comme ça enfin tu vois des quatre
j'ai jamais vu mais lui prend un tempo
du cavalier il a l'air de savoir ce
qu'il fait quoi non mais je l'ai vu il y
a pas si longtemps avoir une partie je
sais plus toute qui mais je l'ai vu il y
a pas longtemps
donc ouais je pense que bon moi je l'ai
vu je l'ai pas travaillé derrière mais
j'ai besoin et il a pas été surpris et
du tout par
partout ça on va dire que c'est pas lui
qui travaille c'est quelqu'un qui
travaille pour lui qui le tient au
courant quoi c'est ça c'est ça
alors du coup Fab ça te dérange pas je
vais juste régler mes caméras non mais
règle donc règlement
donc elle a pris en D4 il sait prendre
et puis on va voir ce que la tête elle
fait ses trois pour attaquer le pion
donc soit les Noirs s'en fiche ça peut
être qu'il faut pousser cinq
il faisait 5 c'est le coup qu'on a un
peu envie de regarder quand même
pour garder le pion
on va vite c'est ça
alors non en fait ma caméra marche pas
le lien le lien youtube que j'ai en fait
et c'est tout noir donc je sais pas si
c'est un problème de la personne qui
s'en occupe
ou si c'est moi parce que mes liens sont
tout noirs je les vois
donc je vais je vais directement
je peux vous mettre qu'un scène je vais
essayer de vous la mettre
beaucoup de Canadiens dans l'équipe
quand même non
je sais pas mais lui c'est possible
du coup
[Musique]
dans la sur la vidéo là pour que vous
puissiez voir
quand je pense au bras j'ai envie de
voir je vais rendre scène à Man etc quoi
peut-être renforcé évidemment mais bon
je pense que j'aurais peut-être un jour
ça aurait plus d'identité quoi j'ai
envie de dire
clairement
donc Arsène il est en place par contre
vesalie moi le lien de marche pas donc
vous avez pas d'Indiens
[Musique]
faut l'imaginer quoi on va l'imaginer
mais en fait tu vois ça devient blanc
après c'est ça
ce que je vais faire j'ai une idée
je vais faire un truc
je vais faire ça voilà excuse-moi je
préfère des trucs
moi de toute façon ça devrait être bon
maintenant
et du coup
et hop voilà là vous allez avoir la
première caméra qui enfin la partie qui
va arriver avec les caméras et pendant
ce temps je mettrai les autres
ça vous serez vous aurez vous pourrez un
peu mettre des visages sur les nombres
en quartier je pense que vous le
connaissez un peu tous mais les chaluts
par exemple c'est pas tous les jours que
vous la voyez le tournoi donc
hop
et du coup je vais passer du coup sur
une autre scène vous pourrez voir
veshali cars scène qui joue hop voilà
et pendant ce temps là du coup je vais
mettre du coup les autres caméras
et
donc voilà donc là je vais mettre Ariane
là du coup tu t'échauffes pour pouvoir
mettre les autres caméras après ouais je
fais tout direct comme ça après ça sera
terminé facile quoi tu cliques et tu
mates
qui attaque un F7
il faut défendre en tout cas il faut
défendre
[Musique]
du F4 quoi histoire d'ouvrir la colonne
aussi
et
puis voir ce qui se passe mais
ok en fait j'en sais rien tu vois je
sais pas
en tout cas ça a l'air enfin je vais au
moins elle prend sa chance et elle a
sûrement raison de jouer un truc comme
ça plutôt qu'une partie technique qu'on
garde scène ou bon en général on est
tous moins fort que lui donc
non pourquoi pas bonne stratégie parce
qu'évidemment elle part pas favori bon
derrière souvent en fait ces premières
rondes comme c'est très déséquilibré
c'est-à-dire le plus fort d'une équipe
donc le moins fort de l'autre etc
souvent ça finit en deux et donc que les
petits lots entre guillemets prennent
leur chance je trouve c'est une bonne
stratégie c'est clair c'est clair quand
toi des équipes on a vu ben autre jour
quand j'ai stream tu avais un joueur
c'était un joueur iranien à 2500 en fait
qui décommommer tout le monde quoi et
donc tu as des joueurs des fois qui sont
qui ont des petits élo tu vois et qui
sont hyper hyper fort quoi donc dépend
des bons joueurs internet intéressant de
voir ça aussi
donc en fait je pense la composition
d'équipe c'est important d'essayer de
trouver des joueurs qui ont un élo
peut-être un peu inférieur à ce qui va
le plus sur Internet etc savoir que
c'est quand même du 10 plus 2 donc c'est
du rapide mais ça va vite quoi tu vois
c'est pour rapide quoi
mais en fait j'ai envie de dire j'ai
l'impression que
l'enjeu en fait pour faire une amie qui
possible c'est de trouver des gens sous
classés
avec ces histoires de moyenne et l'eau
enfin tu vois
en fait je sais pas il y a des trucs
sont bizarres que genre en fait quand tu
es plus que 2007 je regarde scène il
compte que comme 2700
un peu bizarre et aussi que une fille a
plus de 23-5 ans compte que comme 23,50
c'est bizarre aussi je leur
équipe française du coup en bénéficie
quand l'agneau va jouer bon elle est
quand même 25 60 en fait mais donc tu
gagnes 200 points d'eau sur la moyenne
quoi enfin
comme eux là les bras ils ont bénéficié
avec Carlsen qui est je sais pas combien
là 28 60
oui mais en fait si tu veux mettre un
autre enfin
tu prends une fille comme la gnocent un
moment en fait tu as une moyenne tu as
26 50 en fait mais tu comptes comme
25,50 dans les règles c'est ça donc tu
as aussi outre le fait de trouver des
joueurs sous classés tu as aussi ce
ce biais là dans les règles quand j'ai
envie de dire mais là du coup si tu mets
si tu mets Carlsen et que tu mets je
sais pas
où il est fan par exemple bah c'est
c'est quasiment ouais mais voilà en fait
Carson va courir 2016 et où il fan comme
23 ans
et voilà quoi donc en fait là tu rentres
complètement dans dans la moyenne à 25
ans avec cette équipe là avec deux
joueurs largement dessus de 25 50
bon écoute c'est comme ça
quasiment fini mes caméras là parce que
c'est un petit peu bizarre
de toute façon après les caméras tout à
changer à chaque fois
[Musique]
après maintenant chaque partie
qui sait pas comment faire alors
attention franchement franchement
elle est elle peut être très dangereuse
bechali très tactique après Carson se
gardienne on est d'accord mais
elle est quand même dangereuse il faut
faire attention
c'est je sais pas moi j'aurai une
tendance à penser à Dame 7 mais
je sais pas à baquet par du calcul c'est
juste
ça a l'air un peu moins enfin il y a du
F4 qui peut arriver ben ouais
même direct
tu te barres en H1 puis après tu fais
froid
qui calcule mais du coup c'est pas
simple donc Garden là il est en train de
de prendre sa chance et tu vois Carlson
dans ce match franchement bah il peut
faire 4 sur 4 quoi
[Musique]
oui il peut vraiment c'est le meilleur
joueur et du coup bon je pense que les
joueurs qui ont vraiment sur lui
et donc
la semaine dernière
mais oui en fait peut-être que ce qu'il
veut c'est de la FC F4 si on prend cette
rochin et des 5
donc ça s'en fout prend des 5 la Tour
Eiffel est plus défendu il y a pas de F1
tu as peut-être le temps de faire
cavalier 7 et vite OK
et que tu souffles un peu quoi
que c'est pas évident
je vous fais des flèches dans une petite
seconde dès que j'ai terminé ça
et là j'ai tout mis bien à la tout est
bien placé donc normalement maintenant
je suis bon je parvenir sur ma vie de
normale
OK
et ok bah écoute moi je suis bon hop et
du coup ça je vais la remettre ici
et dernière chose que je vais faire
c'est que je vais reprendre
j'ai un souci
c'est bon
par dessus ça me casse tout chelou cette
histoire
[Musique]
à moins que je fasse comme ça
je sais pas ce qui se passe
non il faut que
je déteste là mais j'ai un petit souci
il me laisse pas mettre la caméra et en
même temps ça
bon du coup on va rester comme ça et je
vais changer d'écran mais du coup
[Musique]
il me laisse pas prendre de temps parce
que là du coup je peux pas faire des
flèches
il faut un troisième écran
tu en fait si je mets
[Musique]
attends je sais je sais un truc
si je fais ça
non ok désolé
[Musique]
en fait tout marche bien si je si je
mets en avant si tu veux les caméras et
que du coup je peux pas utiliser les
chéquier chez qui ici avec les flèches
c'est assez bizarre cette histoire
je sais pas comment on est arrivé là du
coup
mais il va bouffer une qualité ouais et
là du coup le petit problème c'est que
si je reviens en arrière
c'est un petit peu saoulant
ce que je vais faire éventuellement là
je vais je vais régler les trucs de mon
côté on va revenir sur une vue comme ça
comme ça je vais pouvoir
remettre ça mais franchement enfin je
sais pas ça n'engage que moi mais les
caméras vaut mieux voir l'échiquier
qu'on suivait des parties et qu'on
puisse expliquer plutôt que ok voilà la
tête des joueurs mais on suit pas les
parties en plus je vous ai mis ça
et puis on va voir
on va on va regarder comme ça puis en
même temps je vais je vais regarder un
petit peu là il y a pas là il y a pas
les il y a pas le temps donc je vais
mettre l'autre scène encore
haute scène qui est cool aussi où on
voit en fait
[Musique]
celle-là là vous voyez le temps c'est un
peu mieux vous voyez pas le score vous
le dira de toute façon
et puis hop donc juste rapidement ce qui
s'est passé il reste peu de temps on va
on va voir en accéléré
il s'est développé ok il y a eu prise il
y a eu cavaler les deux et il faut B2 B5
ouais c'est parti chaud là P5 alors il
veut il veut virer le fou pour gagner un
temps en fait il y a peut-être du Fou B7
qui gagne un temps de développement
bonjour rapidement et fou de cette tour
1 logique
que j'ai 4 H3 cavalier
ok bon enfin du coup
ça devrait marcher
mais bon il a à la fois 3 minutes
d'avance et à la fois c'est Carlson donc
ça doit aller mais du coup si tu veux on
peut les voir un peu les autres
je vais
ça parce que
[Musique]
tu m'as envoyé
marche pas le lien
en fait c'est pas ça alors attends je
vais
en tout cas tout marche bien il me
semble sur le BS
tout marche bien c'est la caméra faute
qui me qui me font un peu défaut donc
pas mal
ça marche
[Musique]
alors gauche on connaît pas trop on
disait tout à l'heure ouais bon
nombreux nouveaux
donc un tout jeune bon là il est marqué
émis mais il est GM et maintenant il a
2500 hello il est jeune et donc bon ok
on va voir un peu ce qui nous fait en
tout cas il a une partie ici ou bah je
dirais qu'il est un peu moins bien
peut-être non ouais il est moins bien
mais il va essayer de s'accrocher
c'est un peu chiant mais bon en même
temps c'est vrai qu'il y a quatre à
défendre et un peu C6 pour les Noirs
enfin les blancs peuvent pas vraiment
attaquer mais qui on va dire limite
l'activité noire et peut-être que ce qui
fait pas d'erreur avec les Blancs qui
n'empire pas sa position ça doit tenir
quoi je veux dire
mais oui ça a l'air plus sympa pour pour
Hunter quoi
clairement oui
tu as le temps qui peuvent rentrer en B6
et
ouais c'est plus plaisant en tout cas il
y a plus d'activité donc on va voir un
petit peu en tout cas mais les blancs
peuvent être ici un petit peu en
difficulté alors si on va voir le jeune
prêt auto Reims van qui est qui est
aussi grand maître qu'elle a il a la
largeur je ne connais pas du tout mais
[Musique]
donc ça doit aller donc ça devenait
c'est un joueur qui a commencé à être
assez connu
sur le circuit donc aux Olympiades il
avait notamment bas de chez Dominguez
donc voilà c'est un jeune il doit
pouvoir combien dans quoi 17 ans 18 ans
ouais par là ouais bah je sais qu'on a
dû le croiser à Porticcio une fois
et
voilà non plus il est bon sur Internet
même sur Internet il est vraiment très
fort donc ouais en tout cas c'est un
joueur qui qui est capable de faire très
très bon score qui est très dangereux
qui jouent un peu très vite c'est un
habitué des cadences rapides et Blitz
tout ça
et tu en ashiki on a du coup vite dit
avec les Noirs contre la jeune Jennifer
you
elle est pas trop mal
ok donc
sur ce qu'on voit c'est net domination
des bras sur le début du match ouais tu
as l'impression que que ils sont pas mal
les bras ici parce que peut-être
et on verra mais ça a pas l'air si grave
pour l'instant
franchement non pas du tout enfin
la finale quoi faut juste faire gaffe au
pire
une qualité de plus on s'est arrêté à
Dame D1
ou ces trois tours 3 foot et 4 on va
changer les pièces normales d'avance
vous pouvez changer les pièces
tour ces trois rois je vais donc là il y
a plus de temps en plus pour les blancs
donc c'est très dur en plus
échanger les pièces
il y a tous les pions qui tombent c'est
trop dur
cavalais prend on empêche faut prendre
un 4 et
5 ça peut presque aller mais après faut
prendre un cavalier prend on se dit on
perd une pièce que c'est défendu et ben
non une fois que je mange il y a tombé
en fin de variante qui regagne la pièce
en fait
partie elle est forte
qualité de plus c'est complètement
gagnant pour pour les Noirs donc Magnus
qui ouvre le score du coup on se match
avec 1-0 du coup pour les chaises bras
on peut aller voir peut-être si tu veux
tarif
allez
toujours plutôt mieux mais ce qui va
conclure
mais normalement il devrait gagner le
pion à 3
c'est un bon début quoi
pourquoi ça me fait ça à chaque fois
en même temps
qui me qui ne veut pas
que si
que si je suis dessus
et du coup je ne peux pas du tout
je ne peux pas du tout avoir avant
mon Obs
je sais pas quoi dire
pour la caméra j'ai envie de dire moi
je comprends pas en fait pourquoi ça
marche pas juste
c'est déjà tout blanc
ok donc cavalier FC donc là on va
changer les pièces
je sais pas ce qu'il y avait surtout
prend à trois parce que je m'attendais à
ça ok
ça va aussi mais sûrement que les blancs
vont échanger essayer de faire des cinq
et tu vois c'est de liquider ton tu peux
quoi peut-être
je sais pas si ça c'est bien j'ai quand
même qui avance vite
bon il a pas fait ça lui donc il a fait
que le F6 et
ça aime des bonnes chansons
pour les Noirs ils peuvent même limite
se retrouver malin en fait bon je pense
jamais en fait tu perds jamais cette
partie mais au pire tu te fais bouffer
il y aura que perpète mais
mais bon je sais pas enfin je vois pas
une organisation en fait non je pense
pas non plus contrairement tout à
l'heure j'imaginais mais là F6 mais bon
du coup les tours on est derrière le
pion a ça le pion il va être perdu en
exactement
les pièces vont s'échanger je pense
qu'il y a aucun cas je pense que F4 fait
tourner 4 et sur le projet 3 tu feras
torche G4 échecs quand j'ai trois
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
je suis désolé je
juste à côté sur le clavier
alors attends je vais te changer quand
même parce que c'est quand même pas très
sympa tu as quand même ta batailler pour
devenir grand maître
c'est pas très cool de ma part
[Rires]
je sais pas si je vais encore assez bien
pour
pour garder
non mais rien sinon tu vois
ça comment tu vas là j'ai vu ta enfin
malheureusement j'ai pas pu assister à
ton à ton entrée fracassante sur twitch
j'étais pris hier soir j'avais un
tournoi de Blitz d'ailleurs vous allez
voir une vidéo YouTube bientôt où hier
en fait j'ai fait un tournoi le but
carnaval et donc j'étais glissant
Pikachu et
j'ai trouvé un enfant de 10 ans qui
était dégueulasse
Pikachu tu vois moi j'ai 32 ans il y
avait un gamin de 10 ans qui était
exactement comme moi pour que je me suis
dit un petit peu bon tu vois ça fait
mais c'était génial du coup on a fait
des photos ensemble j'ai fait une partie
avec lui gamin c'était Pikachu contre
Pikachu ça c'est drôle
à gagner ouais quand même
mais du coup j'en ai fait une vidéo
c'était assez drôle donc là j'attends
qu'on me fasse la miniature pour la
poster mais du coup c'était cool
je sais pas
tenir notre ami indien mais j'ai pas
aimé j'ai pris un f au lieu de tonifier
j'ai pas trop compris la décision
tu avais un moyen de te dans la
merde c'était celui-là quoi
qu'est-ce que je suis bête
la nouvelle chaîne d'ailleurs de Yoshi
est sorti du coup tout frais hier ben
n'hésitez pas à aller voir la chaîne à
follow un petit peu tout ça dans le chat
ouais
un petit un petit saut à Yoha allez voir
d'ailleurs moi je vais pas je m'abonnais
d'ailleurs enfin hop
[Musique]
voilà je suis gefollow faites tous comme
moi les gars
faites tout comme moi
allez c'est parti bon du coup ça fait
nul c'est parti
c'est hyper chaud là j'ai du mal à
comprendre
[Musique]
donc déjà les bras prennent l'avance et
du coup si elle perd pas c'est genre un
massacre en fait mais bon elle est pas
trop elle va elle va souffrir quand même
elle a plus que 6 secondes à la pendule
passer ici qui font mal
je sais pas si c'était possible
[Musique]
ça va être
durer tu ferais tout un tour c'est
après et après tu pousses à fond quoi
c'est c'est perdu non juste
ça pousse à fond et puis à 4 et ton B4
alors en plus il peut y avoir des fois
tu reprends cavaliers avec des
fourchettes quelque part qui traînent
voilà ça va être vraiment drôle
abandon tomber etc salut Fatou katal
voilà 3 2 c'est terminé ok bah écoute
deux un du coup pour pour les indiens
pour les bras pardon donc on va vous
montrer un petit peu je vais vous mettre
l'autre scène donc je suis désolé les
caméras pour l'instant ça marche pas
trop un petit bug
du coup de 1 vos 2 et demi 1 et demi
pour pour les bras avec notamment
victoire de rasman Préaux tout contre
contre
ronax ça c'est quand même la la bonne
surprise bon c'est pas non plus une
surprise de ouf parce que bon tu vois
c'est 2005 en 2006 mais
le troisième lot de l'équipe
qui
donc c'est tu vois dès que tu as une
performance si tu veux d'un échec qui
est en dessous qui va un joueur plus
fort c'est quand même c'est quand même
bien quoi
donc
ok donc pour l'instant pour pour les
bras plus je veux dire dans le contenu
très facile
visite à pas gagner très facile déjà tu
vois enfin entre les deux numéros
et après à l'intérieur il a plutôt
dominé c'est des blancs qu'on suit pour
faire nul ils sont arrivés mais bon tu
imagines couleur inversée peut-être
c'est pas la même alors que
alors que ça doit ni qui est dans le
rôle du dariana lui c'est il se fait
déboîter du coup ils ont l'air beaucoup
plus fort les bras en fait sur la
première on a mais je veux dire ça donne
quand même la tendance du match quoi
après il faut voir parce que là pour
l'instant tu vois première échiquier au
dernier échiquier c'était vraiment
forfait faible et en fait ce qui va
aussi compter c'est pas trop si je pense
les points des des féminines
quand tu as dû un V1 c'est même des
chalet en fait moi je la vois clairement
faire une surprise contre tu vois le
numéro bon
en même temps sur une partie elle est
dangereuse hein
et euh je la vois beaucoup plus
dangereuse de manière générale que you
voilà je garde ok bon d'ailleurs quoi
mais de manière générale je la vois
quand même plus
plus dangereuse que Jennifer you parce
que jenniferio ok la part des vidéos qui
est normal hein peu importe la couleur
c'est logique et après
il lui reste quand même deux grands
mètres qui sont jeunes qui sont qui sont
très bon sur Internet etc plus je vais
Charlie
24/50 quoi tu vois elle a plus de l'eau
les gammes censé être plus forte et
quand elle va jouer contre par exemple
prêt au tout quasiment c'est même mélo
en fait
mais peut-être qu'il vaut mieux que ça
se préauto je sais pas on verra mais en
tout cas pour l'instant il y a deux un
pour pour les bras mais en fait cette
histoire de féminine pour moi c'est pas
clair j'ai l'impression que peut-être
que les Indiens ils peuvent marquer plus
de points à ce niveau là mais en tout
cas c'est vrai que voilà si elle fait
une mauvaise si elle fait une mauvaise
un mauvais match
peut-être parce que franchement Karat
scène devant c'est trop fort et puis
derrière ça tient pas mal tu vois
donc voilà deux un pour l'instant
pour les bras on va attendre la ronde 2
du coup
du sac quand c'est censé démarrer
ben
c'est ça mon sous peu
normalement la ronde de deux ça devrait
devrait arriver
là je te tiens au courant de toute façon
là j'ai pas encore les appareils
généralement c'est là que ça va se
passer la ronde de d'exficié là en fait
ce sera bon je pense qu'ils sont en
train de créer c'est qu'elle qui te pose
entre temps
et c'est tout
donc
voilà là je suis en train de voir
mon problème de caméra c'est ouf quoi
on m'a jamais fait ça de ma vie je
comprends pas
pourquoi est-ce que sur
la caméra quand je suis pas dessus quoi
je ne comprends pas
à moins que j'essaie un truc
je vais essayer un truc
je vais essayer de faire le génie ça
risque de pas marcher mais
quand même essayer de faire le génie
je vais essayer un truc
pendant la pause toute façon pendant que
les joueurs arrivent je vais essayer de
faire un petit truc
[Musique]
je vais faire ça
sans
[Musique]
je vais mettre ça là je me suis mis en
mode
je vais changer
alors attends
je vais le mettre là
ça c'est la bonne
ça c'est la bonne ça c'est la bonne OK
ça me fait toujours le même problème en
fait
c'est un truc maintenant on va faire
ok bah écoute c'est quoi
j'ai malheureusement
pas le truc hop on va revenir comme ça
et on va rester comme ça
tant pis
alors
chez moi n'a pas parti encore
c'est non parce que quand on voit en
plus les quand je voyais les caméras
j'ai l'impression que les joueurs
étaient
concentré comme si je fais une partie
je suis fou ou quoi
[Musique]
elle est là OK
et voir si
il y a quelqu'un mais la ronde 2 je vois
que les je vois les bras contre les
contre les Charlotte
sous la Camargue
[Musique]
et je crois que je sais pourquoi ça me
fait bugger en fait
[Musique]
non c'est bon les gens sont en pause
c'est bien ça et je pense que je sais
pourquoi je bug en fait
je pense que c'est pourquoi je bug je
pense que
malheureusement je pense à chaque fois
que je suis là tu vois je vois que le
la vidéo elle bug en fait la vidéo que
j'ai de chaise 24 es en fait si tu veux
il y a un il y a
YouTube
privé comme ça avec la comme des joueurs
et en fait du coup
[Musique]
le truc il fait que s'arrêter fait que
de redémarrer à chaque fois moi ça
remarche ça redémarre et du coup ça va
être ça la source du problème je sais
pas
parce que apparemment tu vois j'étais
j'avais pas vu le direct de la chambre
directe sur la sur la vidéo mettez sur
les deux vidéos
et là encore la soupe Center je suis
encore en direct
c'est comme si en fait ça c'est bizarre
genre si tu veux c'est un stream en
direct sur YouTube
et en même temps à chaque fois il
s'arrête et du coup il continue sans que
je rentre direct je pense que c'est pas
ce que je veux dire
je comprends mais
en gros ça marche pas en gros ça marche
pas
ça marche pas
et la ronde 2 est toujours pas toujours
pas mise
[Musique]
pourquoi je n'en sais rien
sur le sur le
2 et demi 1 et demi pour les bras
ça c'est la rondeuse c'est pour ça ok
va commencer mais vous avez le score en
bas c'est ça le score en bas 2 et demi 1
et demi et en fait en bas à droite enfin
en dessous de nos caméras vous avez le
score de la ronde donc là les appareils
sont créés
j'imagine que voilà les parties vont
commencer donc là on a caressé avec les
blancs dans cette partie là je vais vous
remettre la vue
ici comme ça voilà vous êtes Catherine
avec les Blancs contre harmoniaque
gauche
qui va débuter dans quelques instants
donc Arsène qui avait une belle vraie
partie quand même pour trouver le Chali
car je pense à envie de faire 4 sur 4
donc on va voir ça serait ouais ce
serait une belle fleur de Lens pour son
équipe quoi ben c'est clair mais en fait
il y a aussi un truc c'est que tu vois
[Musique]
pour gagner le match il faut 8 et demi
en fait donc c'est déjà un joueur fait 4
points
c'est déjà pas mal
déjà
quasiment pli en fait tout seul entre 1
et 2 ça va être arrivé
F3 qui avait des S6 ça a commencé
j'ai trois j'ai trois bon tranquille
c'est pas mal ça évite
les grosses lignes théoriques on va dire
même si bon ça va être de plus en plus
ce petit Reiki et
[Musique]
ça fait jouer ça fait jouer l'adversaire
que juste il récite sa petite théorie je
pense que c'est c'est plutôt plutôt bien
ce qu'il fait qu'un seul tu vois quand
tu joues genre moins fort comme ça parce
que tu as aussi envie de montrer tes
prépas envie de rentrer dans les débats
théoriques contre un joueur qui est
nettement fort que toi bah non
exactement
[Musique]
en fait il va peut-être prendre des
mauvaises décisions etc
et non je pensais bien ça c'est niveau
expérience c'est vraiment génial après
nous enfin moi par exemple je peux moins
le faire parce que moi de j'ai moins
d'expérience et moins de connaissances
tout ça mais tu vois tiens B5 qui était
joué aaroniac oui t'inquiète oui bien
sûr c'est très ambitieux
il me semble en gros pourquoi pas enfin
tu veux mettre un fou sur la sur la
grande diagonale pour contrebalancer le
Fuji 2 qui va arriver était vite un peu
C4
et tu fais finalement E3 quoi
si je joue genre je sais pas assez
souder
5 en fait et
du coup tu pourras peut-être faire A4 ou
des trucs comme ça
alors moi il me semblait j'avais en tête
une idée non je sais pas si c'est
vraiment comme ça
mais avant toute une idée sur sur B5 de
faire C3
je sais pas
par exemple sur fou B7 j'ai ça et il y a
un problème sur le fou et tu défends je
fais ça et c'est hyper chiant
c'est pas du tout c'est
3 c'est 5 il y a eu ces quatre
ouais bon E3 je veux dire
c'est 5 sur A4
après C4
bon en fait
l'idée c'était c'est marrant ça
genre sur trois non c'est genre sur C3
on disait à 6 c'est 4 c'est 5 qui sont
prises C4 c'est un truc ouais qui existe
dans le remontant dans l'autre sens
moi mes connaissances s'arrêtent là mais
du coup l'idée c'est que c'est très joli
en fait parce que là du coup on attaque
la dame en faisant une découverte sur la
tour
et du coup ça ça gagne une tour mais
bien entendu là je vais pas manger en 54
on va non mais bon du coup on est venu
un peu en B3 pour rien quoi
intéressant ce petit c'est 5 mais
qu'est-ce qu'il est joué
ouais bon 3 c'est complètement justifié
là en fait vu la position parce que tu
as provoqué assis ce qui sert absolument
à rien pour les Noirs il sera à 7 je te
porterai pas plus mal peut-être même
mieux je sais pas tu vois enfin et E3
bah il est là donc tu peux être là d'un
mois de temps vit tu peux faire des
quatre tu peux garder
les coins c'est clair
d'ailleurs ça sent un petit peu à une
position de Larusso tu vas connaître un
avec avec un E4 D3
dernière position j'avais déjà vu pas
mal c'était il y avait un match c'était
je crois que c'était 45 ml
d'ailleurs je crois que c'était un
speech mais il y a très longtemps il y
avait la pollution que E4 D3 et personne
faisait que ça avec les blancs avec des
B5 etc bon là il y a un pion raciste
donc ça change tout mais quand il était
là et
[Musique]
il est mal placé ici il est mis en Cessy
donc souvent on fait un prince en fait
pour chaque 6 et donc c'est polissons là
qui ont l'air d'être symétrie mais au
final tes pièces sont mal placées et ça
fait que du coup les Blancs ont quand
même assez l'initiative
c'est vraiment intéressant
donc voilà donc D4 une Lass dessin
français
les ouvertures en fait j'ai envie de
dire c'est pas dans la West indienne ça
peut arriver dans les Espagnols des fois
les Noirs il faut en B7 il y va trop tôt
bah tu l'ambules avec dessin
de primovins
le délai de la partie mais c'est on a
l'impression que tu as pris move des
cinq
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est normal
parce que
tu supprimes pas comme ça c'est un
pardonnable
en équipe comme ça tournoi non tu peux
pas parler aussi quoi
après tu Miss cliques ça autre chose ça
arrive un peu
pas le droit en fait c'est pas
professionnel non c'est pas un père
déjà en fait ouais
bien bien pour quoi
[Musique]
en fait
on peut le dire c'est bon on a besoin ce
côté de chez qui et depuis on décide
tout ça pour attaquer à l'aile dame et
en fait la même elle dame tu as rien
quoi c'est moi qui est là qui est la
couleur c'est moi qui fait placer les
pièces je peux aussi mettre un cavalier
en C4 plus tard ça sera toujours bien
C4 alors hyper bien quand même mais qui
a des deux peut-être qu'il y a cavaliers
de 5 maintenant
et du coup peut-être j'ai pas le temps
de cavaler ces quatre
c'est quoi la différence entre la Benoni
la bonne mélodie la mode Mélanie
alors
bonne nuit
bon des mâles mais tu as du jeu
alors que la mauvaise bénonie
tu es mal tu as du jeu mais moi quoi
c'est un peu ça quoi merci merci pour
cette belle définition
c'est vrai que en fait à haut niveau
c'est beaucoup enfin c'est pas très
respecté quoi tu vois c'est vrai que
c'est une position qui est très
difficile en fait pour les noirs
à haut niveau tu es d'accord hein
je pense que tu es d'accord du coup avec
ton commentaire mais alors que côté
amateur c'est quand même encore beaucoup
joué
non mais la physiquement ça va en fait
mais
les nouveaux ordis aiment pas tellement
et il y a des variantes un peu pénibles
je pense notamment les quatre pions il y
a des ordres de coups dans laquelle
c'est peut-être plus plus jouable que
d'autres notamment
on va dire
souvent si on la voit c'est plutôt des
quatre qui est 6 c'est 4 6 cavalier F3
c'est 5
des 5 décédé
quatre six donc genre tu commences genre
KF3 bah bien sûr tu peux rentrer dans le
candidat tu peux faire foudre
mais c'est ça finalement ici je pense
c'est un des meilleurs ordres de coupe
au jeu de la Benoni parce que
tu as éliminé déjà toutes les montagnes
EF4 enfin déjà le cavalier des gens F3
et à certaines variantes aussi ou
qu'elle y pourrait aller en E2 ou tu
vois enfin
c'est un peu mieux pour les noirs de
forcer ça quoi on va dire moi j'ai une
seule fois la bonne année dans ma vie
c'était parce que le mec il m'avait joué
il m'avait juste ça
ça
encore ça donne une autre et parce
qu'avec G3 bah tu es commune d'avoir gg3
et la vente et G3 elle est pas si mal
pour les Noirs j'ai envie de dire enfin
après
pas là dessus d'ailleurs ça a bien
marché
du coup j'avais fait ça ça et du coup on
avait fait une mélodie quoi mais du coup
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que là
ce qu'on voit c'est je c'est un
cauchemar quoi en plus
le mec qui va tester 0-0 je crois
et de deux t'as pas échangé de pièces
avec les Noirs ce qui est pas bon quoi
ça se tape pas d'espace en fait
c'est une règle sur discord
[Musique]
depuis longtemps mais vas-y je suis de
retour ouais une règle de la Benoni on
va dire si vous voulez jouer ou quoi
c'est qu'il faut arriver à échanger au
moins une pièce légère côté noir parce
que les pièces se marchent un peu dessus
on va dire bon en fait le fonder ça on
voit qu'il est débile il n'a rien à
faire là mais normalement il va être sur
l'autre diagonale mais en fait on s'est
huit il est pas développé il empêche la
connexion des tours et témoins qu'il
soit alors en 17 mais si l'on décède
faut mettre le cavalier 5 bah juste tu
te prends F4 et tu as plus de casque
quoi et du coup tu as une pièce en trop
enfin tu te marches un peu dessus vous
pouvez changer
il faut dégager une des trois pièces
entre le footclasse blanche et un des
deux cavaliers pas lui bien sûr bien
évidemment ça ce serait pas possible du
tout
parce que les cadres sont trop faibles
vous voyez que le foot ce serait pas du
tout possible
ok donc la fois à 8 on peut se préparer
cavalier B5
j'imagine qu'il serait content de faire
5 pour tenter un échange peut-être
justement mais
j'ai pas de cavalier à 5 maintenant
donc cavalier donc là c'est 4 qui avait
le 5 comme tu disais ça va peut-être
aider les Noirs à échanger des pièces
donc avoir un peu ce qui va nous faire
car scène ici
c'est débile de jouer
[Musique]
je sais pas
tu vois tu fais un coup tu te le dis tu
prépares Fiat
je sais pas j'ai 4 mais peut-être j'ai
quatre qui est 4 et tu poses tout
F4 là mais c'est 4 et me dire que si tu
prends je prends et là j'ai F4 vient de
tempo peut-être du E5 en fait ça peut
être genre ça je prends prends et là F4
avec peut-être le fameux cinq qui qui a
un coup qui est important dans une
position
et en fait là pour une fois le Fou est
vide sera peut-être pas si mal pour
éviter stylée mais
peut-être que j'ai quatre et bien je
sais pas ça
[Musique]
et aussi l'idée aussi c'est qu'il y a
plus de problèmes sur le carré la dame
maintenant peut naviguer plus facilement
le moins bon des deux cavaliers parce
que normalement ça casse C4 qu'on aime
bien donc kb6 soit il veut les changer
et mettre le transs C4 soit il fera quel
B2 je sais pas c'est un peu bizarre mais
pourquoi pas pour faire à 4 à 5 et venir
après
mais j'aurais l'impression qu'il veut
des changer pour
pour faire cailler ces quatre en fait
mais écoute c'est pas mal
on va voir donc il a pris ouais c'est ça
et qu'il échange tout il va sûrement
faire d'abord mon peuple ouais il va
être pas mal sans plus il a damaka qui
peut il l'a fait
donc ça gagne un peu non
il veut peut-être faire n'importe quoi
c'est dur quoi
qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici
comment on termine
[Musique]
mais de toute façon rien que le pion a
passé
en 4K
[Musique]
sur en fait l'idée de cavaler à 5 je
serai rapidement c'est de venir en C6 et
si tu prends un 4 je pensais faire ça de
te donner les fous et de faire ça en si
tu prends je prends et ça va être la
crise et là j'attaque le fou et je me
suis tombé vite obligé de prendre mais
bon
ça va pas trop enfin
huit reste en rabbit non mais bon
je pense on peut peut-être zapper on va
considérer que ça c'est gagné
ça va être signé
ok encore une belle démonstration
complètement dégommé
alors du coup
Paris contre vesalie
ok bon il a l'air mieux quand même
enfin B prend des 5 je veux dire tout
reprendre B2 tu auras 5 et bon ben
mais bon
avoir encore mais la présence du Fou
augmente bien sûr les chances de gain
des blancs ce sera que les tours
au final devrait être nul mais là
par une des énormes différences c'est
que tu fais tour à 8 et que tu pousses
le pion jusqu'à A7 au lieu d'avoir la
tour bloquée de pas pouvoir bouger ben
tu as le fouet 2 qui défend le pion quoi
donc
ouais il y a de bonne chance pour ta vie
quoi
pour essayer de
[Musique]
pour essayer de mettre la caméra mais
bon je suis pas ça marchera
après pour B4 te reprend des 5 peut-être
faut juste se barrer en
tour à 8 et
3 à 4
mais bon
c'est mieux blanc c'est pas encore fait
mais
j'aime pas tellement ce que je raconte
j'ai l'impression que sur tour B4 tu
reprends des cinq tour à 8 B3 4 sur la
même tour D7 et chargeur fou et fuite
tour D8
prise avec du C5 qui arrive très vite
tout en reprenant
mais du coup ouais je crois que c'est
c'est
ça va être très dur pour les noirs qui
ont pas tellement de temps en plus
mais on va dire n'importe quel tour
prend en dessin que ce soit
tu reprends à 5 et j'ai l'impression que
tu peux faire tout à 8 pousser le pion
jusqu'à 7 étant donné quoi
bon bah écoute je t'annonce que j'ai
réussi à y aller ce problème
bravo
bah non mais bon c'est complètement
débile
donc
ok les Noirs H5 pour prendre à deux
il va pas faire ça voilà qui pousse son
pion passé
logique tour à deux et ouais j'imagine
tour à 8 et on pousse juste de manière
bête et méchante
faut juste éviter tout Rasset quoi pas
se prendre ton temps
ça va
bon les bras franchement ils sont en
grosse gestion on voit que deux parties
ça déjà être encore de zéro
c'est Laura Carlson franchement tu veux
un tournoi des personnes dans ton équipe
quand même ça je pense c'est motivant
quand même
ça peut te paralyser aussi ça peut être
paralysé ça peut être dur dis bon
qu'est-ce que c'est de la merde il va me
tu vois bah ouais
c'est ça
on va dire ça dépend des individus il y
en a c'est sûr que ça peut se faire
motiver qui vont se dire
quelle chance machin et ça peut aussi
tétaniser
du coup ce que je vais faire
[Musique]
pour les caméras c'est complètement
débile
jusque chrome il me laisse pas faire ça
du coup je passe par edge
[Musique]
alors du coup je vais finir ça
normalement ça doit marcher
alors du coup
pas mal tombé vite a priori
à 7 et ça devrait finir le boulot
bon ben voilà
bon bah écoute c'est bon j'ai réussi
du coup c'est terminé cette partie on va
devoir vite
[Musique]
et il a juste l'air très bien
après bon il y a qu'une minute à la
pendule on sait jamais
ouais bon c'est pas
il est probablement mieux mais tout rêve
3 les noirs peuvent venir un peu gigoter
j'ai pas encore exactement
qui ce qu'ils vont faire de très précis
mais
ce qui est G7 il protège bien le roi en
tout cas
pas mal
cette force
un peu moche comme cou mais bon des fois
faut faire ce qu'il faut faire quoi
en fait je pense que ça ne veut pas
je fais ça
alors
ça me rend fou
ça me rend tellement fou
je vais essayer dernière fois ça marche
pas c'est ça
je vais faire un chat
mais en fait dès que j'en ai deux
ça refuse
quatre
[Musique]
pas le droit blanc
tout d'un coup
c'est plus la fête
mais vraiment ça ne marche pas
ok je suis revenu
ouais bon les Indiens prennent l'eau
même là où j'avais l'impression qu'il
était bien en fait en trois coups qu'on
a regardé c'est la cata
même sans même ces deux OK et à see you
contre ça doit
[Musique]
ton profil
ok ouais ça peut passer c'est vrai que
c'est une belle tête
mais bon ok même là
peut-être dame prend des quatre faut
faire du coup mais d'échange tu pousses
ton pion là
bon je sais pas tu auras 5 ça va revenir
mais tu
as pas le temps de réfléchir tu dois
cliquer
bon ça donne quand même gagner là
et
mes ont gagné 3 semaines avant c'est
déjà 5 et demi quoi
en fait du coup le match il peut se
terminer il peut se terminer plus tôt si
jamais attends je vais mettre le score
c'est parce que trois rondes c'est fini
c'est fini
et donc là du coup
c'est chaud pour les Indiens qui
n'arrivent pas à vraiment à se mettre à
se mettre en scène donc karting qui
enchaîne c'est normal Tariq qui va et
Chailly on va dire c'est c'est les deux
parties qui sont à peu près
normal quoi logique et par contre là la
grosse surprise de Razman qui qui a qui
a battu vide
et ça c'est quand même c'est quand même
pas mal déjà les battu donc il a battu
ça doit ni il a battu le vide
c'est chaud les massacres
donc du coup Cartier
et du coup là il y a 5 et demi deux et
demi et encore trois points sur en tout
huit parties il reste 8 parties
normalement
donc sur les huit parties il en faut
trois points pour
pour
ça
donc prochaine ronde je vais donc je
vais pas apparemment à l'avance là
malheureusement mais dès que ça sort je
vous le donne en tout cas on sait car
scène va jouer contre
priori les Noirs contre ça doit ni
et
qu'est-ce qu'on aura encore on aura du
coup Jenifer ou qui va jouer contre
gauche
donc
ça veut dire qu'il reste qui à orientari
à orientari alors vite vite il sera
Paris
ça va faire du coup on avait dit vite
blanc contre Paris
et ensuite ça va faire ras van blanc
contre vaisselle et
Jennifer you contre gauche Armagnac donc
voilà si les bras mettre trois points
dans le dernier petit match et ben c'est
terminé
ce sera terminé et franchement en gros
c'est qui votre cas des bras parce que
franchement au début bon ok toi tu étais
hyper chaud depuis le début moi j'étais
un peu moins parce que je pensais que
vais-je aller le pouvait enfin quelque
chose et que les Indiens étaient assez
chaud mais au final c'est vrai que le
ras van prix au tout qu'on ne connaît
pas du tout ben pour l'instant il a
enchaîné vite et ça doit ni franchement
1 et 2 quoi c'est pas mal ouais
lui pour le coup c'est un vrai canadien
enfin le Canadien il a un nom comme qui
est bien Roumain
rassval
d'origine
que ça en fait c'est étonnant 99 donc je
veux dire il est à 24 23 24 ans 23 on va
dire
24,94 donc c'est pas non plus tant que
ça rapide à 25 32 enfin c'est pas comme
s'il y a 2007 quoi
il est grand maître depuis 2016 en fait
ok donc c'est pas c'est pas du tout
c'est pas du tout le
jeune qui monte quoi bon il est bon hein
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
ce qu'il fait sa vie je sais pas si il
est pro ou pas aucune idée d'ailleurs je
regarde son profil fille
un peu récemment ça va il joue chaque
mois mais il y a une période où c'était
le covid aussi tu me diras mais entre
mars 2020 et août 2021 zéro partie jouer
après il a joué trois mois il a pas joué
deux mois et le jeu de mots il a pas
joué enfin il est pas là ce fait depuis
août 2022 qu'il a son classement qui est
aussi chaque mois ça bouge un peu
mais rien de quoi
90 mais ok
parce que c'est vrai
ça peut être
[Musique]
non même pas genre limite c'est plus que
lui quoi quand même pas un truc mais
c'est vrai qu'il est à il est à 2700
ouf pour
pour
son niveau
en fait c'est que la dernière fois on
avait le
[Musique]
un iranien qui m'avait vachement
impressionné qui qui voulait hyper bien
il avait 3000 et quelques minutes quoi
il avait 2000 je sais pas 2500 hello en
feed des 3000 et quelques Blitz et du
coup dans ton équipe tu es quand même
pas mal parce que il faisait des supers
des des supers résultats d'ailleurs il
avait deux demi sur trois argent tout le
monde et il a pas de la dernière partie
mais il avait été vraiment monstrueux
quoi
et du coup je pensais tu vois que
ça peut être le cas aussi avec un prêt
auto mais apparemment non préauto qui
qui est un grand maître qui après je
vois beaucoup j'ai vu c'est pas non plus
un joueur qui joue beaucoup sur internet
mais quand même
ok alors est-ce qu'on a les appareils
toujours pas chez moi j'ai l'impression
non
toujours en attente
on a le temps de cette ronde de 3
[Musique]
ok est-ce que tu crois à la remontada
d'ailleurs je ok bon je pense qu'il y
aura quand même il y aura quand la
quatrième ronde
ça serait encore lourd mais bon après on
faut voir mais c'est vrai que c'est
[Musique]
les autres formules voilà fini quoi
c'est quoi ça
je suis assez d'accord mais ok bon
on va attendre de voir mais oui
normalement
va pas il y a une grosse différence en
plus même dans le contenu c'est pas
juste il joue bien et ils sont plantés
ils sont archi dominés dans le jeu ils
sont beaucoup moins forts et tout quoi
est-ce que tu penses qu'il y a une
préparation particulière pour le match
bon les joueurs les gens ont un peu
regarder évidemment
[Musique]
je sais pas à quel point le prénom
sérieux mais si jamais ils le sont
tu te prépares quoi enfin tu connais tes
couleurs tu regardes un peu le
répertoire etc ça semble logique
disons si moi je devais jouer une ronde
je ferai ça quoi je regarde un peu ah
oui non mais bien évidemment bien
évidemment tiens on a des apparu immote
son désagréments je vous avais déjà mais
on a toujours pas les parties dans cette
chaise comme ça que je voulais dire
parce que là on a on l'a vu mais je
crois que tu me parlais de ce que les
joueurs se préparer pour le match non
non je
[Musique]
aussi
donc c'était pour ça mais oui je te
parlais une préparation avant match
a priori ils le font un peu quand même
ce qui est normal parce que c'est quand
même il y a de l'enjeu il y a des prix
et bon il y a des beaux prix et tout ça
et puis après je pense que même si tu
vois c'est quand même une équipe bon
cheesecom tout ça mais aussi une équipe
de potes parce que quand tu vois dans le
Reiki bon je sais pas à quel point
Carson avec les autres il est ami mais
je sais que par exemple avec
sont quand même assez proches
donc c'est quand même cool tu vois de
c'est une aventure quoi
comme ça tu
as pas envie de faire l'idiot quoi par
respect c'est clair et en plus quand tu
es quand tu es Carlson que les gens
comptent sur toi c'est aussi assez
motivant de savoir que les gens ils
comptent sur toi etc tu vois donc
Carsen il a quand même beaucoup à faire
dans ce championnat et je pense qu'il a
aussi envie de leur donner la victoire
cette équipe de chessbra
donc
à quelque chose enfin outre les échecs
qui me déchèques je pense encore plus
c'est pas avoir pas pour rien quoi il
est là pour gagner et clairement mais
après il y a aussi un ça
au niveau de l'intérêt de et de tu vois
je pense que la caracène il est vraiment
il va essayer enfin il joue pour en tout
cas
gagner bon après rarement pour ne pas
gagner
mais là tu vois au niveau de la
motivation bah je pense qu'il prend
vraiment tout sérieusement parce que il
veut vraiment
donner la victoire à ces assez
coéquipier
ou quoi tu vois même si déjà c'est quand
même quelque chose déjà important quand
même il les joues
en plus
tu vois bon tu as déjà vu des des
K3 ou 2 par exemple etc tu vois et là
mais là qualifié enfin moi je suis pas
trop pour le 42 mais
genre ça aurait été une partie qui
devait absolument gagner bon enfin
d'ailleurs ouais il aurait pas fait ça
c'était juste ça c'était les phases de
poules ou en fait genre tu as des huit
premiers qui sont déjà qualifiés il
reste plus qu'une en nous deux il a il a
12 points d'avance il dit oui bon
mais
mais quoi qu'il en soit oui pour
l'exemple j'aime pas tellement perso 8
garde le message de le toune sur le chat
c'est clair tu enlèves le
pied si il est pas là quoi
il fait quoi d'ailleurs il est pas il
est pas dans son ordi
des Français Blitz c'est quand c'est
jeudi à cette heure-là
contre les chinois alors les chinois du
coup ils ont une ils ont une féminine à
2500 hello
[Musique]
la révèle ou pas les noms
c'est limite l'équipe max en fait
c'est GREA
et le fils d'Étienne Alexandre Macron
et donc les chinois ils ont toujours une
zone ils vont oui je pense et puis
d'autres tu vois que je connais pas
vraiment mais ça doit pas trop mal joué
quand même quoi bah je les ai ouais là
je les ai donc
[Musique]
et les petits bac
et
alors que c'est des chinois c'est
[Musique]
et Louis pingouin
regarde tout est possible
on a en 2007 en plus quoi
sur le papier mais tu vois les joueurs
chinois des fois ils sont sous classés
on sait pas enfin moi j'ai vu le match
je les commentaires
et les
Chinois derrière ils étaient pas si
impressionnant
clairement bah écoute peut-être que donc
bon en tout cas avoir mais ça va être un
match chaud et un match cool en fait en
plus à suivre donc
à voir mettre sympa
ah mais sur le papier on a l'air favoris
quoi mais
après voilà c'est un joueur qui qui est
qui est pas en forme ça peut être chaud
donc
tu as appris au tout la petite qui te
fait mal quoi
donc prêt au tout
non
[Musique]
sorte de d'espagnol avec cavalier 7
cavalier
beaucoup je suis pas expert mais j'ai
l'impression que de prendre des H4 assez
facilement quoi
absolument
mais
[Musique]
je connais absolument pas ça a l'air
très bizarre quand même perdre deux
coups avec ton Caval pour venir ici une
case assez bizarre finalement c'est
plutôt cavalier
ça joue à 16h30 c'est ça alors je
connais pas trop le décalage horaire
avec les chinois mais tu dois être un
horaire à peu près normal pour enfin
peut-être il y a 5 heures de décalage ou
je sais pas mais peut-être c'est 21h30
pour fin donc ça va encore mais oui si
on pouvait faire jouer à 2h du matin ça
serait bien
ou oui c'est chaud
en fait
OK
c'est pas mal ce qu'il a fait vite je
trouve
ça me fait penser à une variante de
l'écossaise et après
tu joues un truc comme ça souvent
mais là du coup on est content de
l'avoir pour viser la case des 5
l'avant-poste
[Musique]
pas très bien mais je enfin moi je
préfère aller blanc ici en tout cas ah
oui à quel point c'est grave
il y a une position comme ça en fait
avec le cavalier
c'est la fameuse position de
l'écossaise en fait non pour essayer de
se libérer
donc en tout casser mais souvent tu peux
manger juste
et il y a toujours un petit problème sur
la structure un petit peu mais avoir F5
F5 Mathieu cornet le chat
d'ailleurs j'ai une partie de référence
tu vois la fameuse écossaise avec
si je parle de foubec
et ben cette ligne ce qui m'a donné
envie de la jouer une partie de Mathieu
ouais
[Rires]
un ami je crois
et il avait fait il avait massacré avec
les Blancs et j'ai vu j'ai vu cette
partie j'ai dit en fait c'est bon soit
c'est Mathieu qui est fort soit c'est la
nuit qui est forte je me suis dit bon
peut-être que les deux en fait mais mais
au final après j'ai commencé à bosser ça
et c'était vraiment cool et du coup
j'aime beaucoup cette ligne bref du coup
je considère que c'est un peu bizarre
[Musique]
mais ok c'est Mathieu qui m'inspirait on
va dire pour vous dire je pense que ça
plutôt une valeur de surprise
tout le temps fou B4 c'est peut-être pas
le meilleur choix pour les marques à qui
tu as travaillé la ligne autant faire
qualifier quoi mais d'avoir une fois de
temps en temps
ouais je pense que je vais
être
en 2010
[Musique]
le problème c'est que ça sert pas à
grand chose pour les échecs
je me souviens pas des coups j'ai juste
tout ce que où est la partie et entre
qui et quand mais souvent
tu as des trucs que tu que tu gardes en
souvenir tu sais il y a un truc qui t'a
marqué dans une partie ou un truc tu
vois enfin c'est
mais
bon moi de toi par exemple les souvenirs
[Musique]
il me semble et
moi je jouais le tournoi j'avais 1900 et
l'eau
ça devait être en
[Musique]
2008 ok
je suis pas sûr de l'argent 2008 mais tu
as joué en 2007 mais peut-être c'est
2008 et que c'est un truc comme ça entre
2006 et 2008
et bon je te connaissais pas l'époque je
te connaissais de nom tu sais voilà
[Musique]
tu es fort quoi
toi
mais bon ça c'est marrant tu vois
je pense que j'avais plutôt enfin en
fait j'ai toujours mal joué à mon tour
donc ok
[Musique]
le Festival des Jeux à Cannes c'est un
peu les premières fois que vous avez vu
en fait si tu veux en vrai quoi et maso
c'était un tournoi Festival des Jeux à
Cannes ça a joué pas dans les c'est la
salle actuelle dans une autre salle
je sais pas
on avait joué là où il y a eu un
championnat du monde de
Blitz
ça avait eu et j'avais joué là il avait
fait un bon endroit et il était en 2006
alors
habillé en ouais ton gay maillot de bain
et il était hyper fort et je me suis dit
mais c'est qui storiste
et il était en pleine progression à
l'époque et tout et bon moi j'étais
jeune avec un 16 ans encore je
connaissais pas encore les gens tu sais
moi je voyais s'amuser je sais pas qui
tu étais tu vois
juste avec laquelle tu dis bon retourne
à la plage
mais
c'est vrai que Mathieu dans ce tournoi
il m'a pas fait un combat
Mathieu c'est pas cette année où je l'ai
euh
quoi donc n'arrêtez pas de temps de
Matthieu je l'ai pas remarqué par contre
Mathieu j'ai un souvenir de lui
encore une fois au fils non c'était pas
le Festival des Jeux pourtant à Cannes
mais stop panne Beach il avait et il
avait 2000 quasiment 2400 Hello
une année il joue le tournoi il y avait
plein de gens comme ça et
il y avait déjà l'occasion de 1400 à 15
ans ouais mais peut-être moi j'avais
loupé cette année
donc tu imagines bien quand je l'openber
c'était moins de à l'époque c'était
moins moins de 2000 moins de 1900
comme ça
OK
d'être en 2005
je sais pas bon mais
un peu la clique là qu'on mange tous
connu enfin connu parce que c'est vrai
que j'ai commencé à faire les tournois
je restais chez moi j'étais une histoire
je joue le pain de Nice tous les ans il
arrêtait et c'est tout en fait et c'est
que vers 15 16 septembre je commence à
sortir un petit peu et
un peu quoi quand même
c'est super loin quoi mais
[Musique]
mais non mais c'est vrai c'est marrant
quoi
[Musique]
parce que là donc
c'est pas non plus ouf mais un peu mieux
quand même
ça
et la première fois que j'ai vu
[Musique]
la première fois dedans mais j'ai vu une
anecdote je la ferai pas bien sûr
t'inquiète pas mais le peine de Nice
c'était assez drôle la miss des prix je
pense que je pense que s'en souvient
encore
j'étais en tête à la dernière ronde j'ai
perdu un pion en quatrième coup
non mais je sais pas beaucoup quatre
coups
le mec qui me joue un pion en noir j'ai
un peu en E5 images de cavalier F3 pour
attaquer mon bureau 5 et je me suis dit
je cavaler le sac avec le fou j'ai fait
h6
il m'a fait cavaler merde
j'ai perdu
après bon ok ça ce sera en off
[Rires]
[Musique]
je préfère les blancs mais bon on peut
se passer des choses
mais je sais pas si j'ai raison préférer
les blancs c'est juste visuels
qui peut être éventuellement une cahier
vraiment
[Musique]
mal quoi c'est ça et tu vois aussi bah
la part de fous noirs quand même qui
tape sur le roi donc le canal qui peut
sauter à bondir à tout moment
le score si vous voulez mais du coup ça
fait 600
et 2000 ça fait 6 à 2 et demi là
[Musique]
il fait pas grand chose mais en fait
j'aurais eu les Noirs il me joue pas
peut-être que je voulais même coup
non mais tu dis si ça doit ni il joue
contre il joue contre quelqu'un sans
avoir conquis il joue bah il va jouer
beaucoup mieux
mais normalement oui si je joue contre
moi il va pas jouer comme ça
les gens des fois ils ont tu as
l'impression qu'il joue avec le frein à
main tu vois
comme si ils avaient ils avaient peur
enfin je dis ça bon bah ouais ça fait
peur mais en même temps moi le danger
quoi
[Musique]
à main tu vois une partie non mais
qu'est-ce qu'il faut quoi
donc il y a un peu plus pour les blancs
non non pardon
il y a la case D4 un pion isolé en
dessin
le seul regret quand on a l'impression
c'est qu'il y a un pion F3 mais
peut-être qu'il y a pas eu le choix
avant et voilà
ça serait pas la même parce que du coup
il y aura le fou qui se réactif et puis
le pion de 3 qui se trouve c'est bien
solide et là sur le long terme on peut
avoir des fois des petits problèmes sur
l'option 3 éventuellement donc c'est pas
le pion isolé le enfin le c'est pas le
meilleur purger de la vie mais ça a scan
une position assez intéressante
faire attention manœuvre aussi à base de
cavaliers B6 cavaler ses quatre qui
peuvent aussi être à des propres
problématiques par rapport à la taxe
champion à droite
[Musique]
sauter bon au moins les exercices il
peut l'enlever trois peut-être ok elle
est vite
un peu sceptique là j'aime beaucoup les
noirs
solidifier tu fais des de torcer un
spécial mais peut-être que ça va mais
pas plus je des blancs sont pas mieux
mais
[Musique]
va pas être plus faible que le 3 non
voilà souvent on peut des fois tu
m'attaques le mien et puis on va chacun
se manger le pion mais là pour l'instant
je vois même pas comment tu peux
attaquer mon pied en fait
j'aime beaucoup les Noirs
je suis assez d'accord avec toi après
je veux dire je sais pas à quel point
c'est grave pour enfin j'ai l'impression
que si tu fais pas trop de conneries tu
dois quand même pouvoir soit quand même
pouvoir aller
et puis rien en fait mais pour ces trois
enfin je sais pas des coups comme ça là
où tu
ouais faut pas trop vouloir faire plus
OK
mais du coup est-ce qu'il peut
finalement le match les braves s'ils ont
six et demi il faut deux points sur
trois
il y a prito qui est pas mal et s'ils
font si lui il y a et qui a de nul
il y a le match déjà en trois rondes
pour gagner
le match direct et paquet 3e
4e match donc visite contre Paris donc
c'est targane et là ça peut être chaud
trois quatre cinq six ok donc c'est on
taille qu'il y a 43 secondes dans la
pendule contre 4 minutes
qui peut sauter il y a effectivement
[Musique]
mais bon à voir si vraiment c'est grave
ou pas le truc c'est croyant tu vas tu
vas faire à 4 après les blancs alors au
bloquer il faudrait faire Damas 3 mais
c'est en fait une tour à la rigueur et
la dame derrière dans ce sens là c'était
moins et là du coup tu auras 8 ça a du
sens pour faire tourner 3 sur tour 1 je
pourrais manger manger et tu auras deux
d'ailleurs cinq mais je peux quand même
vous montrer l'idée c'est que ça ça je
pourrais penser à manger à deux mais
attention la contre-pied pointe avec
d'un point F5 et sur un point F5 et
maths du couloir
donc là pour l'instant tout droit a
l'air de tenir j'ai envie de dire
comment est-ce qu'on peut jouer sur
autoroute
[Musique]
ou alors tu fais un petit tour reprends
vite des familles d'abord
[Musique]
et sur à 3 j'ai plus d'entrer j'ai
encore un peu cette c'est quand même
et bon pareil que cavalier
[Musique]
il voulait G4 et
les dames des quatre et partir à
l'attaque du roi qui est des 7 tu vois
et rentrer partout donc en tout cas tu
arrives il est reparti que ça dame il
attaque à trois avec la tour au moins
elle a rien c'est pas mal
c'est chaud
ok les blancs
non non c'est pas faim il faut il faut
encore terminer ça il y a plus de temps
il y a 17 secondes à la pendule pour
pour Paris
c'est important pour les indiens pour
pour rester en vie que visite gagne mais
bon j'ai l'impression que pour
l'ensemble du match ce soir il y a pas
trop de semaines
je voudrais je suis pas une avalanche de
mauvaise nouvelle pour les bras en fait
du misclic de la déconnexion qui tourne
en même temps
sinon j'aime beaucoup la position de
végétalie
avec sa part de fou maintenant ah bah
c'est vrai qu'il absence de souber 6 par
rapport à tout à l'heure ça change de
trois trucs
[Musique]
ou pas d'échanger les pièces
il y a aussi qu'on peut changer
j'ai pas d'échec là-haut il faut les
trois fois
pour je sais pas en fait mais par
exemple
c'est du couloir effectivement mais bon
tu peux prendre B6 ou je sais pas quoi
avec le rond H1 des fois vous pouvez
attendre d'un match 4 d'un point H3 vous
voyez parce que depuis on peut pas
manger à cause de plage
pourquoi pas
est-ce qu'on peut jouer un coup de style
je sais pas je propose une idée du style
foot
[Musique]
tu feras une autre batterie en gros je
veux faire un truc je vais faire ça
et ça
et sur ça ça
tu vois voilà je peux bouger je m'en
fous peut-être vraiment je parle là
parce que du coup
j'ai pu
[Musique]
c'est à dire qu'en fait bon là tu me
lasse pas vraiment de bon si je mange là
d'en prendre déjà par exemple tu as plus
mais bon on va revenir enfin
[Musique]
allez reste plus de temps une minute
pour les blancs contre 27 secondes pour
les noirs
donc
on verra ce qui se passe
il a fait très vite elle a fait très
vite H5 je me demandais si genre fallait
faire Damas 8 pour ne pas laisser
échanger les fous
mais bon ok c'est fait c'est fait et je
sais pas c'est juste une vraie question
qui empêche
[Musique]
l'impression que quand on a la paire de
fou c'est
ce que ça il y a de bonne chance de nul
en fait
[Musique]
et que ça favorise le temps qui attaque
donc là ça va être les Noirs clairement
ils ont un fou plus fort le roi est plus
faible tu as l'impression que quand même
que tu as un pion de plus au final
quasiment exactement mais en fait ça va
être dur de mater quoi
toujours échangé mais faut le poser
c'est pas trop c'est pas vraiment le cas
parce que
il y a trop de blocus
[Musique]
mais comme je ça va pas être facile de
gagner du tout
même pas gagnant en fait mais elle a la
raison de gagner enfin elle a raison de
jouer en fait
de perdre à moins de tomber ou quoi
l'échec alors roi des 6 je pense
OK
ça tourne ça tourne
par contre d'être bien entendu ça va
aider 5 probablement
et on voit de Vivario qui a perdu donc
il y aura il y aura du coup une tonne
c'est la perdus ça va peut-être faire
trop un pour les Indiens ben là il va
gagner là
du coup
tu croyez pas la remontada pas du tout
et là bah du coup
non mais en plus
il était hyper bien après tout
quand on avait la pression avec le fond
elle se dit que le chou va rater le pion
et que et que voilà
je crois j'aurais mille fois
c'était pas mal aussi
ok abandon
et demi autant intermédiaire vu Carlson
avait gagné
c'est ça
et donc
OK dans la partie qu'on va voir dans
quelques instants
avec peut-être d'ailleurs à la clé des
partages on va regarder un petit peu
donc la dernière partie je vous la
donner ça va faire du coup Carsen blanc
contre vidydite il faut qu'il tienne
vite pour avantage car certaines mains
qui a 3 sur 3 et qui
et puis en plus bon là il y a plus trop
de
[Musique]
il nous a présente pas trop dans le
match mais non il sort sa partie
maintenant c'est le moment on va dire
après on aura à Rognac
avec les avec les Blancs contre contre
ras vannes
c'est marrant parce que près au tout il
a battu vidite ça doit ni
donc voilà et dans la partie ce sera du
coup le choc des féminines avec les
chalet blanc contre Jennifer you qui
pour l'instant à zéro mais ok c'est dur
en face c'est 2007 2650 2550
tu peux faire un des 0 sur 4 sans que ce
soit honteux dans ce temps-là ah oui non
mais clairement
c'est c'est difficile
c'est difficile donc du coup
du coup voilà ça prend quelques instants
donc si donc en fait oui ils ont besoin
de faire juste deux points
deux points sur 4
à 1,5
et ainsi par deux
donc du coup ouais ok c'est bien que les
Indiens soient revenu sur moi ça me
laisse de un peu de suspense
c'est cool c'est cool ce soir
est-ce que c'est prête c'est prévu tous
les jours non je pense que je suis même
pas dans la liste en fait ah ok mais il
y a enfin il y a une place on va dire
libre encore au cas où il y a un
problème donc s'il y a besoin je peux
dépanner mais je veux dire ok je pense
pas que je serais trop une plus-value
quoi donc on peut trouver mieux quoi
après c'est mieux que je joue plus qu'on
va se forcer
il y a Mathieu dans la vie il y a Maxime
Lagarde
il y a Étienne
et il y a Maël et Alexandre donc un peu
plus moins classé qui aide à la
descendre la moyenne et qui sont jeunes
et qui pour le coup sont pas mal et il
peut être dangereux
donc en fait normalement il y a toujours
des compos possibles tu vois il y a
quand même pas mal de joueurs après si
personne peut ou quoi
si j'en sais je veux bien mais
parfois ça me dérange pas de commenter
de ne pas jouer quoi
après c'est dur c'est c'est au niveau 1
il y avait une année on a voulu faire
une équipe une année finalement c'était
un peu c'était compliqué on a même pas
fait les Blitz on s'était pris un petit
peu tard on voulait faire une équipe
avec
avec Barbie avec Adrien Demuth avec
Quentin l'oiseau etc et bon celui qui
est sympa tu vois bon il y a pas de star
hein
parce que quand t'as pas de stars comme
ça et
et
déjà là nous on était content de se
maintenir
un match c'est fait donc au moins c'est
bon et après on verra la suite mais
ouais c'est assez fort en fait donc
c'est hyper fort il y a pas d'équipe en
fait non non je sais pas trop le budget
des équipes tu vois mais ça se peut que
des équipes qui envoient pas mal quoi
et tu penses du coup que la Process
League enfin moi j'en sais rien après je
sais même pas comment fonctionne Blitz
quoi que ce soit
mais les gens sont payés pour jouer en
fait
alors pas forcément tout sous quoi et de
toute façon il y a des prix donc après
il peut être rétribué grâce au prix mais
en fait je sais pas des joueurs
il y a des joueurs que j'imagine mal
joué gratos on va dire quand tu vois la
liste des joueurs
dans les tournois ou quoi
après là c'est particulier c'est c'est
une fois de temps en temps depuis chez
toi
et puis à la fin tu as quand même tu as
quand même un gros pactole à distribuer
c'est en équipe c'est sympa
je comprends mais en fait du coup je me
demandais juste si parce que après mais
il y a même d'autres équipes toi
mais il y a plein d'équipes tu vois
quand tu arrives à faire venir des
guéris tu arrives à faire venir du
carwana du seau enfin des mecs comme ça
sans parler de de
tout le meilleur joueur du monde en fait
qui sont qui font partie
[Musique]
ils ont un manager ils ont
un capitaine enfin tout un agencement
après ce que j'aime bien dans ce genre
de tournoi c'était le fait de jouer en
équipe moi je trouve que
c'est
un truc qui est motivant tu vois plutôt
que pour toi-même ou quoi tu as c'est
plus cool c'est plus sympa c'est plus
cool
et puis en plus c'est une aventure après
dans les quarts de finale c'est en live
les demi-finale c'est les États-Unis
enfin tu vois c'est sympa
moi j'avais joué à l'époque
je pense plein de gens dans le chat
et c'est pareil tu vois ces équipes de
cinq joueurs et toujours poker etc et tu
as les califes et en fait je trouve que
c'est sympa tu vois aussi bon j'étais
une année on était on était on est
obligé la dernière calife pour aller
pour aller à
ok cool tu avais du blanc et Vegas je
crois que c'était 4 premiers quatre
premiers Vegas quatre suivants Dublin et
les 8 suivants c'était du cash et on
arrivait à la bulle de Dublin voilà donc
on a pris du cash mais ouais
c'est cool
9e sur je sais pas combien de centaines
de milliers d'équipes
et
en fait nous on rêvait d'aller à Vega ça
du plein si ça c'est monstrueux tu vois
et du coup
du coup bah ça fait rêver tu vois tu dis
les gars on va aller à la Vegas
il nous file je crois qu'il nous filait
tout ce genre Dick à chacun pour les
tournois plus l'hôtel plus l'avion
partout
mais maintenant c'était c'est cool tu
vois c'est genre moi je suis pas genre
je suis complètement nul j'adore ça mais
je suis nul
mais du coup le fait de jouer en équipe
etc tu vois c'est c'est
quoi
c'est sympa alors
toujours ça va arriver
ça va arriver avec un point de plus pour
l'instant 16 bras qui mène dans ce match
3 sur 3 pour l'instant un joueur blanc
franchement
complètement injouable ce qui est ouf
parce que franchement quand tu le vois
jouer quand tu babattre tous ces gens-là
qui sont très très fort tu vois c'est
les meilleurs joueurs du monde
[Musique]
c'est facile ouais c'est facile alors
que nous on les joue mais en fait
c'était moins facile
et il se rend compte à quel point à quel
point juste il est au-dessus quoi c'est
c'est un truc de fou
clairement c'est moins facile
le concept était assez intéressant parce
qu'en fait tu veux quand tu arrives à
ton échiquier et ben en fait donc la
commande c'est 3 minutes
3 minutes plus quelque chose
surprise on sait pas encore et ça dépend
ton déguisement
alors moi je pense que ça pourrait être
sympa de faire ça et plus tu as des lots
de temps en fait
[Musique]
faire des matchs un peu par Handicap
quoi bah quand à 2004 et que tu joues un
1500 bah tu joues avec 30 secondes
et puis c'est un crémant sur un truc
comme ça
contre 3 minutes par exemple tu vois bon
finalement c'était pas ça le truc mais
c'était plus du coup
en fait tu lances un dé
chacun dans son dé et en fait ça te
donne ton ton
ça te donne ton incrément
donc moi je lance
un deux donc moi plus de
6 ou 3 + 6 voilà c'est un petit thé mais
ouais mais en fait ça va enfin ouais non
ça va et puis quatre parties d'affilée
ou moins adversaire avait une seconde
incrément
je joue un gars j'ai quatre contre deux
donc moi j'ai quatre contre deux ouais
j'ai 4 secondes moi et puis je joue un
coup il y en a plusieurs qui me reste
encore 2 secondes je dis mais mecs en
fait depuis le début je me sens
incrément donc lui il avait un crémant 2
secondes et moi j'avais zéro incrément
et du coup je devais avoir un avantage
je suis complètement carotté au final
bon j'appelle l'arbitre il m'a rajouté 4
secondes tu vois et j'ai fini par gagner
mais
c'est chaud
bon du coup la partie terrassienne qui
joue qui joue B3
les trois des cinq fou B2 c'est 5 E3A 6
donc là du cavalier F3 et D4 pour jouer
contre ce petit tour isolé enfin pas
encore du tout en fait c'est une sorte
de western ouais c'est vrai que quand on
regarde comme ça c'est comme s'il avait
joué avec les avec les Noirs merde un
temps de plus mais il est blanc voilà
c'est ça et
du coup
[Musique]
mais
bon
ça marche pas de pain et ouais bon
j'imagine
c'est 4 pour avoir la pause ouvrir
une sorte de ouais
je pense qu'il joue plus dans l'esprit
de colle peut-être avec les deux fous
des trois et quatre agents
[Musique]
qui peut arriver quand même
mais bon
[Musique]
parce que nous C4 soit tu savais qu'un
allié de fout des trois et 84
pour changer un peu la structure
en fait rapide et ben si tu changes les
pions au final c'est
un truc
quand même
[Musique]
mais bon après puis on prend cavalier
prend quand tu prends là je te reprends
je la colonne ton fou il a un petit peu
hors-jeu en 7
un peu mieux pour rentrer en D6 et
dernier truc c'est 8 ça passe
solutionner son développement
contrairement au fou B2 qui donc tu as
des micro détails en fait je veux dire
c'est pas grave pour les Noirs mais mais
voilà on va c'est pas rien du tout non
plus
un peu plus de mal à l'imaginer je pense
car elle prend alors quand même tout à
fait standard pense il va faire qu'elle
prend aussi pas fou franche je me dis
qu'il y a des seins
et puis il faut baisser
B5 on peut aller en D6 alors au moins
qu'il y a un truc qui nous échappe mais
au moins voilà
[Musique]
la partie importante
il y a que un point d'avance pour les
bras donc rien n'est fait encore dans le
match du coup
[Musique]
avec des cartes
en gros c'est pas trop
risqué pour les blancs on va dire c'est
un truc ou on joue pour un petit
avantage et si nul mais oui la raison de
pas s'envoyer en l'air et puis et puis
ça peut bien tourner aussi ses positions
c'est pas complètement rien mais ouais
c'est c'est une vente
d'un point
avec Carlsen qui va
marquer quand même
c'est pas si mal de de
[Musique]
en l'air d'autant plus que ça doit ni il
est quand même il est dangereux
ok
donc c'est ces anglaises avec la case
des 5 mes machins OK
donc là je vous montre la partie entière
j'aime bien j'ai trois
D6
et là en fait sur les cases blanches
D5 notamment
la tête ici
ça va du coup de voir jouer plutôt aller
droit sinon oui F5 et du jeu là bas
il faut aussi cf5
et balancer ici
en fait les Noirs ils espèrent faire des
cinq mais là c'est fini ils vont pas les
blancs sont trop en place et
donc faut bien faire quelque chose sinon
les blancs vont juste mettre un qui est
en dessin
faire B4 et jouer ils vont faire voilà
ils vont bien donc il faut réagir de
l'autre côté
donc ouais les Noirs ils vont jouer
là-bas mais ok ça joue et
du coup les filles donc c'est quoi qui a
les blancs
sa vie qui a des blancs et c'est une
pétrole c'est ça
et une pétrole elle croque opposée
F3 j'ai 4 balancer des pions là-bas
bah écoute c'est une tête pas mal pour
les blancs mais
mais après c'est encore
dur à dire sur H6 tu joues F3 ou comment
on peut se laisser manger alors je sais
pas comment voilà essayons ou je sais
pas quoi mais
je dois avoir prise là encore
je montre juste ça ça
on peut peut-être juste faire
enfin
on le laisse toutes ces pièces attaquer
et bon je sais pas
on va monter à tour en H4
[Musique]
et j'avais pas vu mais bon je vais
prendre ton truc la tour au moins
et je vais prendre un cadeau
[Musique]
faire attention il y a plein de
magouille quand même dans tous les sens
OK
pas trop trop de suspense là dessus là
le fou il va où il va aussi
la faute de mieux c'est pas que c'est le
rêve mais j'ai l'impression que que les
noirs sont vachement en retard dans
l'attaque
et je ferais bien ces quatre avec les
lampes
en fait ce truc enfin qui m'embête je
sais pas si c'est embêtant mais il faut
des trois c'est clair qu'on lui mette là
et peut-être les Noirs font ces quatre
il nous enlève
pas un peu la queue entre les jambes
alors après avoir si provoqué ces quatre
on est content pour amener le fond sur
la diagonale en 5D 4 ou 3D 4
c'est une possibilité c'est quand même
des cinq strain de faiblesse mais bon si
on C4 ça va aussi aider à faire B5 B4 et
couper les Ch'tis en deux on va dire ou
des damassins
alors que si on fait ces quatre
peut-être on
on interdit ça c'est le cas donc
surprise là j'aurais du coup le super
fou la super case etc on est plutôt
doublé et puis après on peut revenir
avec le fou aussi il peut lui-même on a
une belle diagonale là aussi
mais surtout c'est 6 du coup on garde la
tension et on sait pas trop ce qui se
passe
un peu plus de mal la position elle est
pas tout à fait fermée moi je ici avec
les Blancs franchement je ferai chacun
je pense
[Musique]
ça commence à avoir du sens mais avant
pas trop
[Musique]
vite ou je sais pas
c'est un coup quoi
bah en fait j'aimerais
quelque chose avec mes pièces
oui mais les blancs
sur une bonne diagonale
c'est maintenant c'est c'est aussi un
peu dans l'idée l'idée c'est que
maintenant sur C4 il y a la pion arrête
qui quasiment en l'air ouais jusqu'à
Vallier le fou qui tape dessus mais
défendu par cavalier 6 donc en fait si
j'arrive là je peux me dire ok sur ce
cas je peux manger ici intermédiaire
après manger achète d'accord en fait ça
a beaucoup de sens c'est pour ça que
maintenant il y a pas foot aussi il y a
pas de ça j'aime beaucoup son coup
d'ailleurs
il faut 5 je trouve que c'est assez
[Musique]
donc avoir un peu ce que ça donne
mais il faut aussi que c'est cool en
gros je te dis vas-y ben on joue un coup
tu as pas 36 coups non plus moi je vais
faire
peut-être pas genre 8 c'est peut-être un
coup qui t'a pas de si mauvais
mais je sais pas si bon non plus mais je
veux dire au moins ça perds sur le champ
des trois tu fais comment
je sais pas mais peut-être
peut-être H6
mais
du retard ou alors tous les trois faut
regarder si on peut faire
votre bizarre si on peut faire C4
F6
enfin c'est un peu bizarre de neige
j'aime pas trop
donc là je peux le laisser
vraiment tout je pouvais le laisser
cavalier pour faire rage prend pardon et
ouvrir la colonne h mais là ici est-ce
que c'est possible ça sortait trois ça
transposerait dans ce qu'on a dit tout à
l'heure on va parler de C4 enfin de pour
tout revit il faut les trois regarde là
troisième pot
elle jouit tellement la pression
et surprise déjà
ça commence à
ce que donc là il faut voir s'il y a pas
de C4 j'ai quand même deux pièces en
prison
mais bon
même si bon
c'est un peu
en fait on a un fond muret quoi si je
prends des 5 je pars une pièce non
ok j'ai encore du jeu enfin genre
peut-être que j'ai dû
quand tu manges peut-être
une colonne fermée
mais là du coup
qui joue ces quatre il reste la minute
contre 62
c'est parti elle peut être vraiment
importante
parce que enfin normalement sur le
papier wechat est plus forte
et
[Musique]
les les Indiens sont menés de un point
donc c'est la cassette parti ça pourrait
relancer un petit peu
donc là de plus en prise c'est très
chaud
et on va voir un petit peu
ce qui va se passer
est-ce qu'on se revoit un petit tour
rapidement
à cause de ce petit fou et les blancs
quand même position quand même plus
agréable tu vois tu as la paire de fou
mais oui c'est à laquelle celui qui aime
pour les Noirs
enfin pour une fois Carlson n'est pas en
train de massacrer en 15 coups
après effectivement il a un potentiel
plus grand d'attaquer le roi d'adverse
et d'ailleurs je pense une très bonne
décision de visite d'avoir regardé ce
cavalier sinon dames ses yeux damage 7
on aurait pu rentrer et là comme ça
c'est pas bête alors peut-être qu'on
peut tenter je sais pas aller au 4 pour
quand même essayer de courir après ou
caviage de je sais pas enfin à voir si
on peut y arriver mais
[Musique]
je pars
c'est un peu relou pour visite je sais
enfin à quel point ça pourrait aller
mais il faut quand même trouver des
coups précis parce que dès que je joue 4
ben cavalier prendre
c'est ça tu peux pas pousser à cause de
la diagonale qui s'ouvre
de prime abord mais ça reste un coussin
quoi pour ces 8 Caval le 4 tempo
complètement ce qui se passe le cloué
donc il y a pas encore de découverte
pour l'instant il y a pas de cavalier BK
au pire en fait quelque part des deux da
et puis peut-être qu'il avait envie de
donner la dame moi je sais pas regarder
M6 il a gagné le cavalier
moi j'aime beaucoup quoi ça non on va on
va voir rapidement si tu veux
voir ce qui se passe 3 4 5 6 7
mais bon a priori je vais être mon foot
j'ai cinq minutes
pas mal il détruit les pions
tout peut arriver je sais pas mais il
peut gagner ok
tu vois comment ces positions de 4
cavaliers souvent c'est c'est un peu
d'être drôle quoi et là il y a quand
même de la vie
c'est bien c'est un bon coup sur G5
[Musique]
ça généralement c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle pour les Noirs quand un pion tu
arrives à baisser là
[Musique]
pour l'instant il peut peut-être nous
faire un dessin pour nous bloquer mais
bon mais il y a aussi advers
si gauche le gagne que ça doit ni il
arrive à renverser la situation avec
gagne bah c'est fini ouais même si
Magnus gagne
mais ok à voir il y a eu BF5
du coup donc tu as gagné la case des
quatre c'est ce qu'elle voulait sûrement
quand elle a joué au sein que du coup
maintenant est-ce que le cavalier il est
prena parce qu'après ce prix
je pensais du bluff je suis pas sûr à
100% pour le coup là
merci pognard Salut à tous salut
l'hypophyse poignard ou je sais pas quoi
mais bon F4 F5 quand même
rien du tout
[Musique]
le four en prise tout quand même
non je sais pas
[Musique]
je crois pas du tout
je vais manger je vais faire ça
et tu ne feras plus rien du tout
bon ok bon c'est pas enfin faudra voir
la décision qui est là quoi
mais il y a du jeu je veux savoir ce qui
s'est passé ah il a mangé en C5 il a pas
mangé tu vois
[Musique]
et du coup
ça change la lecture du match quand même
complètement ça donne quoi
qui va perdre vite
et derrière il faut marquer des points
chez
nous qui va gagner
parce qu'il a ils avaient 5 secondes
chacun
blanc les bras quand même ah oui
[Musique]
très vite il a déjà une pièce devant en
plus
OK et bah du coup ils sont passés devant
là non ils sont passés devant ils ont un
point d'avance il reste deux par contre
il y a cette ennemi 6 et demi point
maintenant
et du coup bah il leur faut un et demi
donc là celui-là si jamais Rasen terre
c'est fini
c'est quoi la pendule il est très
secondaire
mais bon ça a pas beaucoup l'idée
[Musique]
en même temps qui a mangé G7
une pièce de moins OK
c'est ouf quand même
pas du tout réaliste
à tu sens que la tactique sur de 5 tu as
l'impression que
[Musique]
même s'il fait fout des quatre voilà il
est juste bien il est beaucoup mieux en
fait
il a plu mais il a un fou des quatre
ans franchement il a un de flou
et tu auras 7 j'imagine
pourquoi pas il se fait un peu de place
pour son roi
je fais trop de trucs quoi
est tactique qui peuvent arriver que
cette part de fou là c'est
[Musique]
intéressant
en plus
je pense que là je serai rien à faire en
fait
on se prend pas la tête on défendait
trop rare je pense c'est un lieu donné
[Musique]
trois tours en fait
trop bon d'être cool comme ça
ça
le genre indien mais c'est mat quand
même
ça
franchement tu vois il faut jamais
vendre la peau de l'ours alors parce que
Blitz contre les Indiens
[Musique]
c'était la même
ouais
c'était archi dominé de toute façon
c'est pas les mêmes joueurs là d'un coup
en fait non c'est clair
[Musique]
non mais le score
non mais si c'est nul
et là ils ont tout perdu depuis
ils sont peut-être deux et demi à 25 et
demi quoi en fait
c'est un truc de fou
et bon ça aurait pas changé de toute
façon le score même si personne avait
gagné ça aurait été
quand même donc les scores individuel je
peux vous les montrer on va voir un
petit peu qui on va blâmer dans ce match
je crois que c'est scorboard que vous
avez ici dans les yeux on a personne qui
a fait quand même trois sur quatre
[Musique]
un et demi ça c'est pas terrible sur 4
quand les numéros 2 non
pris au tout 2 sur 4 bah écoute il a il
a battuces
et Jennifer you zéro mais bon c'est pas
enfin
c'est difficile c'était possible c'est
plus Tarik
alors toi je t'avais dit que à l'inverse
il fait 3/4 ok bon bah c'est le premier
échec et il est fort c'est pas pour moi
c'est pas scandaleux
2 sur 4 ben écoute à peu près standard
il a fait son match aussi et donc deux
et demi par contre gauche c'est quand
même pas mal ça
portait et deux vaseline
dangereuse qui était capable de de plein
de choses et à la battu du coup 2500
hello et le 2345 donc Vesali
pour moi en fait sur le long terme elle
est plus forte que que ça fait quand
même plus de points avec alliance je
pensais mais bon c'est vrai caractère en
fait tu peux pas compter tout le temps
son caractère des fois il peut en perdre
une il peut faire des nuls et donc ta
carte c'est bien mais après si personne
enfin ça c'est pas trop derrière
c'est tu vois et là c'était le problème
du match
en fait au final
donc du coup dans les Indiens qui qui
passent du coup à 9h30 donc qui gagne 7
parties contre les chessbra et donc on
va avoir un match du coup tout à l'heure
donc malheureusement on va pas de stream
pour vous nous on va couper donc le
match je vais vous l'annoncer on aura du
coup la TEAM Charlotte Cobra contre la
team la team Brasile
capybaraas donc je sais pas
je vais te dire ça donc les Brasil
Brasil du coup non on a Artémis maréco
Martinez c'est une belle équipe
clairement et alboré donc une fille à
2234 donc Artémis il est chaud
enfin il est très chaud d'ailleurs
Mariko Billy forme en blitz sur internet
je sais pas trop ce qu'il vaut
Martinez Cantara lui il est hyper chaud
sur internet tu as 3100 à peu près
francescom et la fille à 2234 je la
connais pas mais bon
mais bon voilà quoi
et du coup
chez les Charlotte Cobra on aura du coup
au parraine quasiment 2016 c'est un gros
groupe client aussi
on aura aussi la France a une grosse
équipe aussi ça fait mal au Paris au dos
de ski
qui lui en blitz c'est un genre hyper
dangereux
et au 3 on a Jacobson Brandon qui est
aussi un gros un gros bizarre
donc comme une grosse équipe costaud et
en quatrième élo c'est la féminine
Gabriela antova que je ne connais pas
qui a 2300
en tout cas ça va être un match très
sympa malheureusement nous on suivra pas
mais du coup on vous dit à demain donc
demain on va streamer
le match du coup de
pas de bêtises
je sais plus
je sais pas ce sera pas avec moi
je sais pas avec qui je suis demain
demain a priori j'ai pas la date là
je crois que ça va être ah oui on va
stream attends je crois que je dis
n'importe quoi mais
[Musique]
on sera encore là et donc moi je serai
live je sais pas encore avec qui je
serai là d'ailleurs
à partir de du coup 16h30 comme
aujourd'hui pour pour un seul match donc
je vous remercie à tous et puis attends
notre tête notre belle tête à tous les
deux donc je vous remercie et vous dit
du coup
à demain pour de nouvelles aventures et
à très bientôt merci à toi Fab d'être de
rien à très bientôt ciao ciao